[Music]  a purchase on a horizon you just look  him thank you the hesitation in your  voice zone to be an echo in the recesses  of the spheres of retail  the dress is your image unto what you  project through an illusion  just going on a date I don't normally  wear this kind of thing be bored your  date will complement you I would like  you to announce the numbers to your  telephone oh one six three two  [Music]  and stuff as promised look different oh  my god that looks nasty maybe just the  washing powder I hope he isn't catchy  how's it going shooter everything's fine  oh I'm too young what's your machine  went bananas  you who wear me will know me it's just a  cheap bit of mystery I think something's  wrong with that first don't tell me  you're scared of a dress  cryptic to pieces Spanish banking homers  [Applause]  anything nice in the sales just a dress  [Applause]  you